this in a trial it is witness in the
trial of DEA agent Camarena and we are
anxious not to cause any problems with
respect to that trial so in accordance
with an agreement with the US attorney
we will hold that testimony for the time
being that will be made public at some
time in the future or there will be a
public hearing secondly Admiral Murphy
was due to appear tomorrow he has been
detained in California will not be able
to be with us tomorrow tomorrow was
going to be a short day anyway so we
felt that the better thing to do was to
proceed with the closed session and and
then hold our public hearings at a later
time secondly with respect to Monday I
already announced but I want to
reiterate there is an important segment
of this story that will be told but it
must be delayed from Monday because of
the need to have one of those key
witnesses appear in the Middle District
of Florida with the US Attorney there
again in a matter that is currently
underway and again this committee does
not want to interfere with that process
and so we are honoring the request of
the US Attorney and that will
necessarily because we want to tell a
whole story rather than be sporadic
delay the proceedings of that day today
we are going to proceed to tell one
whole story
a piece of the contra drug story but I
want to emphasize that these hearings
are about the larger aspect of narcotics
narcotics trafficking and while today
focuses obviously on the Contra question
and on the private aid Network question
what I really hope it will do is
underscore the
way in which clandestine efforts private
aid networks were taken advantage of by
the narcotics process and this is one
more demonstration of how the narcotics
business has permeated yet another area
of our life and also I think taken
advantage of pre-existing networks or of
ones that were created for other
purposes and I think it is an important
story there will be five witnesses who
will talk about their personal
involvement in either guns or narcotics
or money as part of this network that
was assisting the Contras there will be
one witness whose name is mentioned by
many of those other five who will deny
some of his involvement but I think the
story will be well told and fully told
the first witness is mr. Gary Bette
snart mr. Betts 'nor I ask that you
stand please and raise your right hands
so that I can swear you do you swear to
tell the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you God I
do
please be seated you state your full
name please
Gary Lane Bette sner your date of birth
three nineteen forty one where were you
born
Akron Ohio and you are currently
incarcerated in federal prison is that
accurate that's correct sir okay what
are you serving time for importation of
cocaine how many years is your sentence
twenty seven years and two months this
is the first time you've ever been
sentenced to jail yes and is this only
your second arrest in your lifetime
yes sir had you prior arrests or did
this period of involvement in drugs been
involved with drugs no sir I haven't
now let's if we can I want to elicit a
few questions from you that tell
something about you and your background
I'd like to ask you you say you were
born in Akron Ohio but you didn't grow
up there did you
no sir I understand my parents were just
passing through and where did you go to
Arkansas go to school in Arkansas yes
sir I did through what level senior year
of high school that's correct
what high school did you go to devolves
Bluff high where is that that's in East
Central Arkansas on the white river
about 50 miles east of Little Rock what
did you do after high school I went into
the Navy what how long were you in the
Navy for over four years what I have
here is County reserve time what years
was that 59 through 63
what were your tours of duty well I was
on the aircraft carrier for a year and I
spent the balance of what aircraft
carrier server the USS Hancock CVA 19 on
the west coast we toured the Far East
and then your subsequent tours my
subsequent tours I went to a navy school
for approximately six months and then I
was assigned to patrol squadron VP 17
out of Whitley on in Washington that
would my entire term you were honorably
discharged that's correct sir with what
rating I was enlisted man east six I
believe did you have you previously
attended college at all no sir I hadn't
I attended while I was in the Navy some
and
after I got out during the course of
your naval career did you also do some
anti-submarine warfare patrols
yes sir I'd approximately three years I
flew three different tours in Alaska my
specialty was electronic countermeasures
and did that come to serve you well and
some of your efforts in drug smuggling
later on yes sir I did
we'll get into some of that later after
you completed the tour of service in the
Navy did you then go to college yes sir
I did
where did you go to college Arkansas
State Teachers College did you graduate
uh no sir I didn't how many years did
you spend there I quit after I'd gone to
school there almost a year what did you
then begin to do well I didn't know what
I really want to do with my life at the
time and so because of my past
experience I was hired by global
associates which was the logistic
support contractor the Pacific Missile
Range out of Kwajalein Marshall Islands
how long did you do that for I was there
for a year or so then I left the island
and went back to terminated my
employment after I got back to the
States went to Bellingham Washington
where I had had friends and then I later
moved to New York at some time did you
go to Arkansas and begin farming yes sir
I went back there my parents had a farm
and I went back there and 6566 I believe
early 66 and at that time you kind of
settle down and became a crop duster is
that accurate that's correct
when did you get your commercial pilot's
license I think I got it in 64 what
ratings did you receive at the time I
only had a commercial license since then
you have received what ratings airline
transport pilot multi-engine commercial
single multi engine land and helicopter
and I'm also an A&P mechanic now are you
while you were in Arkansas you started a
crop dusting business is that correct
that's correct sir did you also become a
member of the JC's
yes sir I was JC Mason and chart
remember they're Shriners in Anchorage
Alaska and did you achieve a position
within the JC's we wants president of
your JC's and that's correct sir
where was that Hazen Arkansas now how
long did you run the crop-dusting
business for about 12 years
during what when did you stop the
crop-dusting business in 77
he went to Alaska for a period of time
yes sir I went to Alaska in 7576
and you kind of drifted at Alaska a
little bit no sir I moved in bought a
home in Anchorage moved my family there
went to work for a company there that
ran helicopters for a while and it was
the name of that company international
air taxi and sometime you left Alaska
yes sir I did
where did you go we moved back to
California for a while and Newport Beach
and then after that we moved back to
Arkansas what did you do when you got
back to Arkansas crop-dusted I began to
crop dust I was going through that year
but I subsequently got arrested in Miami
Florida okay now at some point then when
you returned to Arkansas did you attempt
for the first time in your life to buy
some cocaine yes sir I did you never
tried it and no sir actually I haven't
known and on this occasion when you
tried to buy some you actually got
busted during that first purchase is
that correct yes sir it's true where
were you busted a Miami Lerner and what
happened after you got busted what did
you do
well after I was released on bail I went
back to Arkansas what'd you think
crop-dusted for a while then what then I
jump on I was afraid of going to jail
because extenuating circumstances and
the MBA
as per the whole thing and my parents
and none of my family had ever gone
outside the law and there were good
normal people what did you do once you
jumped bail I left Arkansas on a
motorcycle and went to California and
did you then become involved somehow in
drug smuggling while you were running
away from justice yes sir early 1980
describe how that came about well I
lived in Hawaii for a while and then
Oregon and I ran out of money and I
acquired a job in Miami and I moved down
there
I had reestablished myself under and not
another ID you were then known as Lucas
harmony is that correct yes sir that's a
name you chose yes we did and did you
then start to work for Decca aircraft
that's correct
what were you doing for them just
general things washing airplanes
painting airplanes just general things
like that were you doing any flying no
sir not at the time you had an accident
while you were on the job correct yes
sir I thought off of an air Florida 737
wing between a checkstand and broke the
small bone in my left leg so you were
during during a period of convalescence
you met a friend of yours who was
involved in drug trafficking yes sir
that's correct and that was the
beginning of your career yes sir
would you describe how that began well I
met this guy and he had a friend who had
an airplane and they were in the
business and mostly there in what
business and the marijuana business and
one of them had a connection in Colombia
and he made arrangements and gave me the
aircraft and what had what kind of
aircraft was that this was an old twin
bonanza did he make an arrangement for
you to fly to Colombia to pick up drugs
and that's true what year was this I
believe was 19
early early 1980 now let me just
caution you here is I have the other
witnesses and I want to do this publicly
because from here on in your testimony
is is very important to what this
committee is looking at and I want to
caution you that as you know you're
under pains and penalties of perjury
here you sworn to tell the truth and
this committee does intend to hold any
individual as accountable as we can in
the full measure of the law if you don't
tell us the truth and I want to be
certain that you understand that before
we go on I understand pretty well your
sentence right now is how long 27 years
in two months
eligibility for parole is when I haven't
been at the parole board I don't have
any idea okay and you have had no
conversation with this committee or
anyone to do with it have you regarding
any parole or any kind of efforts this
committee would make on your behalf none
none whatsoever though and is it fair to
say that you are also prepared to say to
this committee some things that you have
not yet said publicly yes sir
now mr. Betts are what would you
describe to us this first drug venture
you went on you never flown down there
before how did you know where to go
well I'm a pilot and I've had
considerable navigation experience so it
was relatively simple for me to do I
just left southern Florida and the
aircraft had eight hours of fuel and I
made it to northern Colombia what they
call the wider desert the strip on the
lake which is about almost in the very
tip of Colombia I had reckoned all the
way down and just by compass the
aircraft didn't have any modern
navigation equipment I was in the
daytime I got there the marijuana was
there but the gas wasn't the gas got
stuck in the desert and so I didn't get
fueled until probably ten o'clock that
evening
I took off I flew back found the eastern
tip of Cuba it was a starlight night
flew up the northern coast of Cuba
approximately 20 to 12 to 15 20 miles
off the coast until the saw the lights
of Miami my designated landing point was
the keys in Florida I arrived there
there was some trouble with the strip I
was supposed to land on understand the
customs or some one had was there and so
how did you know that was their company
to warn you yes I communicated by radio
to the ground what was it to the ground
or to some other entity to the people on
the ground where we were waiting for me
to unload the aircraft they told you
there was a problem right so where did
you go I went the next nearest strip
because I had eight hours I feel and
I've been in the area eight and a half
hours as I recall someone into Marathon
how much were you paid for that run I
originally contracted for $40,000 but
because I saved the load I charged the
people extra ten grand
when you say you saved the load when you
got to marathon nobody was there or well
no one was there and I had to take care
of it myself
now why let me ask you a question
of curiosity why would a drug effort
that makes thousands of dollars and here
you are being paid fifty thousand and
they're going to make a lot more on the
load not fly a more sophisticated
navigational equipped plane with these
people were just young people that were
into entrepreneurs you might say into
making a few dollars just in the start
of their life that's the way I picked up
mine so you just took whatever aircraft
was available at that point I took the
only aircraft that they had available
did you in fact get more sophisticated
aircraft at a later time yes sir I did
did how many flights did you do for
these people that that person I think I
did another one for him and
a couple more for different people were
they all to Columbia no they were a
couple of to Jamaica what did you pick
up in Jamaica marijuana do you bring
them back to the same location in the
United States no different locations you
want to name where you took them to well
Gainesville a southern Florida in your
Okeechobee and what too near Okeechobee
did you perform other surface other
services for drug traffickers besides a
pilot in what capacity in any other
capacity did you do any other things for
them besides fly planes yes sir I owned
a company at a later date this is after
I had was actually in 83 84 I had a
company at Tamiami Airport that did
aircraft maintenance mostly installing
tanks and that sort of thing now during
these four flights did you have occasion
to fly over into Cuba again yes sir I
went across Cuba three times during
these first four ventures yes sir well
weren't you worried about violating
Cuban airspace well the first time I had
to go across because my auxilary tank
that the people that installed for me I
didn't function properly and I didn't
have another fuel to go around the east
end so I had to go across Cuba and it
was an overcast day and I was about
12,000 feet I was in a single-engine
aircraft one of those bonanzas that were
approved for aerobatics and they
launched the MiG's on me midnight teens
and I pulled out my shirt and I was
waving it like a you know white shirt
and they made several passes at me while
I was you know leaving I was going north
and and then it made another pass at me
and he wasn't coming around
to pull up beside me was coming up on my
tail so I roll the aircraft upside down
inverted what they call it a split ass
and went through the clouds and I broke
out about 3,500 feet across near an air
base called camaguey Air Force Base lots
of military equipment aircraft large and
small went across the island going north
down through a ravine and zigzagged all
the way over to Jamaica and when I got
to Jamaica I loaded my load whoo about
45 minutes to west and headed north and
about 20 foot off the water hit the
mountains in Cuba and went back across
Cuba in the daylight on the ground and
sometimes I flew below the sugarcane you
know and made it across had no problems
and I got to Florida bout five and
evening Southern Florida and flew to
Gainesville
the guys were supposed to have a remote
strip there but they didn't and they hit
a pig or something going out this trip
and messed up the truck and so I went
into Gainesville and and they had some
people waiting for me there and that's
about the end of that did you have any
problems with the customs or anybody
coming into US airspace
unfortunately no did you take any
special measures to evade or avoid that
no I didn't know that in fly low and at
that time as I recall through the
shipping channels just south of Key West
or there was a considerable amount of
shipping and I would be below the the
ships on the water and if there it
wasn't a radar they would be able to
take me besides when you're heading into
the radar you're less profile than you
are when you're sideways to it
how much of the load did you bring back
in those first four flights each time
what the first load is about 1,500
pounds the second load was about seven
800 pounds of sinsemilla which is a more
expensive substance the other two loads
were 15 1,600 pounds in those aircraft
did you develop an airplane modification
business for drug smugglers during this
period of time yes sir I was in that
where did you handle that out of out of
ten am ii this was part of your avionics
and mechanical operation alright i had
recently set it up to just service my
own aircraft but i knew other smugglers
and you are rated as Navy annex
technician yourself yes Ryan okay now
how many hours of flight time did you
have when you began your adventures as a
drug pilot I would say fifteen thousand
plus you are a very proficient pilot
that was a good flier and a pilot and
when you distinguish the two you're
talking about being able to fly by the
seat of your pants versus the
instruments so yes I'm fair to say was
the crop-dusting good training for the
kind of thing you had to do yeah the
best after you ran these first four
flights did you then stop or did you
become involved with other people no I
didn't stop it became enough involved
other people what did you become
involved with then well I did a few
myself and I lost my first load I lost
had bad fuel now to Columbia Anna in a
queen air and I couldn't make it so I
had to go into Bimini what kind of plane
were you in a clean air Beechcraft clean
air flying from Columbia yes sir back to
the United States you lost your engines
what else do were you at well I lost my
engine I was about
5,000 feet east of Andros I lost one
engine and it seems to fuel as bypass
filters in the fuel to the engine engine
was starving or flooding out actually
and so I continued on and I was about 50
feet off the water
approaching the florida coast and the
other engine fuel warning light came on
and so rather than go in the water I had
to go to Bimini and so I was near Bimini
and I turned in a vor and the right
engine quit and the left engine quit and
I kept starting and restarting engines
and I made it into Bimini what happened
when you got to Bimini well no one saw
me and I ran the aircraft off the runway
under the bushes was another wrecked
aircraft were and we left the aircraft
and my co-pilot ran off and at this time
I had put so much into this that I just
was determined to save it and so I
unloaded about 300 pounds into the
jungle and and I left and went up to
survey the isle and see what was going
on anyway I wound up losing the load and
that night I was arrested with the
Bahamian to help me unload the rest of
the marijuana and they held a gun on me
and I finally admitted it was mine and I
told the sergeant they had the gun on me
that I had 300 400 pounds in the weeds
in the jungle and I'd give it to him if
he'd let me have my aircraft and so he
agreed and the Bohemians shot the lock
off of a dc-3 there and took two
55-gallon drums of fuel and ploughed up
with my wings importing the aircraft and
and I took off it was about 10:30 and I
lost an engine on takeoff and I nursed
it all the way to Florida and I was
trying to get into opa-locka West but I
lost both engines they wouldn't run
anymore so and feathered them and landed
after the tower had closed in opa-locka
at some time very shortly thereafter did
you meet mr. George Morales yes sir I
went back over to Bimini the next day to
find you why did you go back to Bimini I
was going to try to buy in the load that
I lost their back and when I got there
Bahamian introduced me to George Morales
employee
Jairo Plata it was a Colombian American
and Jairo knew I was a pilot and what I
was about and so he introduced me to
George it was at the big game club
George was in a fishing tournament there
and he had a boat by the name of the bar
bet very nice fellow and we struck up a
rapport and he just took me right into
his family and did he know that you
dealt in drugs at that time no no sir I
didn't I wasn't a dealer I'm not very
good at that sort of thing I'm just a
pilot then he know that you flew drugs
yes sir he didn't know prior to that but
during the course of that conversation
he came to know that you did that yes
sir
and did you know anything about George
Morales and his involvement with
narcotics
no I had never met the man before did
you come to learn during that
conversation
that he might be able to use your
talents as a pilot flying yes I did and
so in fact you entered into a business
relationship with mr. Morales to fly
narcotics is that correct that's correct
when did you do your first narcotics
flight for mr. George Morales probably a
week or two weeks I think after I met
him did you learn anything about George
Morales cuz background about things he
did what he was involved in oh yes as
time went on we became quite good
friends what did you learn about it know
that it was from Bogota Colombia that
had been in a construction business he
would been an import-export and all
kinds of different things and uh he just
a very charming witty a nice guy to be
around did you learn that he had any
special talents with respect to boats oh
yes he was into boats and he was a
smuggler when I met him
he was quiet he was into it at the time
he also a competitor competitively
internationally in speedboats yes he was
when I met him but he was getting into
it at that time in a big way and he
later only became worlds champion and
raced all over the world now how then
did you come to do your first flight for
Jorge Morales when George gey gave me
this old beat-up Aztec and just to see
if I could do it I guess and it was my
test and so I was successful and where
did you fly to to Colombia and back to a
great Harbor key I was supposed to go
into another Island and but I couldn't
find the island and so went into another
strip that was an unlit and but it was a
star like night and I found the strip
and I landed there and I had met it had
been in this place before and I had met
a couple Bohemians and they just
happened by luck to have been at the
airport that night and we unloaded the
aircraft and they took it to the north
end of the island and and we got some
gas out of the preachers aircraft there
and put in my Aztec and I took off about
2:00 in the morning and and finally
found the island where we were supposed
to meet was that again a flight from
Colombia yes where did you pick up the
goods in Colombia same places before
um near there yeah the the deserts quite
large in northern Colombia approximately
as I would call of so many probably 3040
miles inland so you landed with the
Aztec that was your first load for
George Morales and it went successfully
that's great okay did you have to pay
off any Bahamian officials in order to
be able to land or to bring the goods in
well actually that's the first time we
started working in great harbor from
from that experience own we paid off the
people and and from that experience on
we worked out a great harbor it became
our home
so to speak then when you say you paid
off the people did you personally pay
people I did a few times later but most
the time Jairo Plata handled that aspect
of it
I knew the Bohemians before he did but
there was a another operator working out
of there the name of Enrique Jose
Enrique Lopez alias Henry Lopez who was
a former partner of Kojak
Gavin Emma Kojak I let the record show
that the gentleman known as Kojak
testified before this committee I think
a year and a half ago and we have his
full testimony which corroborates much
of what these other witnesses have said
and will said mr. Kojak has since
deceased of a natural causes in the last
year but that testimony I believe will
be released at an appropriate time
subsequent to this hearing
now did you do some work with this
gentleman named Kojak and Lopez I no sir
I never worked with Kojak he was at the
time was a DEA informant however I did
work quite closely and became good
friends with Henry Lopez did how many
flights did you then begin to do for mr.
Morales I think that was in 1982 I did
50 for him pretty quick 50 flights yes
sir all two we're all alum BIA
no none all that weren't economy I did a
couple out of Jamaica in the beginning
what year are we talking about now 81 82
and Aryan what kind of plane did you
graduate from an Aztec yes I flew a 402
that I had the george cessna 402s
and it would modified considerably and
then I told Georgia we could do a whole
lot better if I
a better aircraft and and so we got a
panther what kind of plane is a panther
a panther is a piper night Navajo we had
the early model which was a light
aircraft and has 350 horsepower lycoming
engines with four bladed q-tip props
this increases in performance on
considerably what's the normal growth of
that plane that you could carry in
marijuana well most people can with say
two hundred and forty gallons of fuel
they carry seventeen eighteen hundred
pounds now this aircraft I used to fly
it with 320 gallons of fuel and I've
hauled as much as 3,000 pounds did you
get did mr. Morales buy several of these
planes yeah we after awhile we called
his place the zoo and so many Panthers
are now how many Panthers did he buy I
know four or five so mr. Morales had
other pilots flying for him in addition
to yourself yes sir did you get to know
some of those other pilots no as you
know I was a fugitive and I I carried
myself that way I didn't associated in
public or come and go I met some people
but the only pilot that I knew where
they were a couple but the only pilot
that I knew it was Richard Healey who
was George's chief pilot at aviation
activities who did who is mr. Richard
Healey
he was George's chief pilot as I said
and he was a Colombian American his
father was American his mother was
Colombian he was bilingual good
helicopter pilot good pilot a nice fella
where did he live he lived in Miami and
who was he married to do a girl named
Marta
she used to be Marta jhamora and she
married she's a Nicaraguan and they were
married and they had one daughter and
the Richard Healey that was married to
a Marta Healy was also flying narcotics
with you is that accurate yes sir he
made a few trips with me and this is the
same Marta Healy who at one time or two
times actually was married to Adolfo
Papo tomorrow is that accurate yes sir
okay and Adolfo Popo tomorrow you know
to be one of the leaders of the southern
front are de contra movement is that
accurate
that's a Kurd and did you know him to be
somebody working with Adan Pastora in
Costa Rica and no sir I did not know at
that time no doubt at that time you came
to know that later yes sir okay now
the record should show here that Marta
Healy is under subpoena to this
committee we have been talking to her
attorneys she has still not appeared
here in the Washington yet but she is at
this moment under subpoena did you fly
both marijuana and cocaine in the course
of these 50 flights no sir marijuana and
pills cuales yes sir
where did the Pollard's come from
Colombia you flew those all to the
Bahamas yes sir and the nature of the
operation was that you would offload in
the Bahamas yes sir and how would the
drugs then come to the United States by
boat whose votes George's and then he
would have other people contracted to
other smugglers that that was there
especially mostly Cuban what kind of
boats would they use just a varied
amount of the cigarette titan you know
speedboat did any Bahamian officials
ever fly with you on any of these drug
plans yes sir on several occasions how
did what what was it that God a Bahamian
official into an aircraft with you on a
drug flight well I spent considerable
time in the Bahamas flying the baseball
team around in George's dc-3 was about
whose baseball team the different
islands had different baseball teams and
I don't recall each specific one the
police baseball team the defense
baseball team you know and they are in
the baseball and I flew politicians
around and officials around that was
just part of the service and I got to
know a lot of people and and then they
got to know that I was a good pilot and
I suppose and and so offer let them go
along with copilot which was just good
business
and we usually paid him $15,000
when you say officials can you be more
precise about what kind of an official
is with a Bahamian police force
officials any customs or not that would
called any customs immigration I knew
some knew a lot of them but I think they
made enough money that they made enough
money otherwise that they didn't need to
fly the aircraft and some of the Defence
Force people what did you mean when you
said that was part of the service when
you described flying the baseball teams
around what is part of the service mean
well George was always into being
control of the situation and he's a good
businessman and so the politics in
Bahamas were conducive to good business
and so he would you know loan his
aircraft to different people to just as
you know what you'd call it and goodwill
goodwill yeah how much did you have to
pay officials in order to have them look
the other way or take part well you
usually don't wanted to pay them about
15,000 a trip which was was reasonable
because the customs integration get five
apiece in the military or the police on
the island would get five and after a
while they would get greedy and so when
they would get greedy we we we started
kicking it out on Loran fixes off the
island and and we had Bahamian Islanders
working with us that would pick the
bales up and bring them back in and then
we loved them on the speedboats and
bring them home did you perfect water
drops during that process yes ready can
you describe that well we have two boats
out approximately a mile and half two
miles apart at a certain position
prearranged Lorena fix they usually went
in by ground they didn't have
I ran but I would use mine I ran to find
them and they would light flares and I
would descend about a hundred feet on
instruments open the back door and have
an experienced kicker there and they
would just kick the bales out what do
you mean by an experienced kicker was
somebody that wasn't afraid and to do
the job and they were strong and and
could do the job quickly have to make
about three passes and it was all
instruments it was subsequently several
people lost their lives trying to do
that but we did that and then the
Bohemians would agree to our prices and
would usually go back and start landing
again how much money did you make
working during this period this was a
first sort of period that you worked for
mr. Morales correct and this period went
from when to when I've talked to George
about this too and as time is kind of a
strange thing and in those days I would
say the late 81 to the end of 82
there was a eight month period in there
where I did 50 trips for George not even
several for Henry but I know there was
50 I did for George and I made two
million dollars 40 thousand a trip he
paid me for every trip did you during
this time have occasion to again fly
over Cuba um one day I was teaching
George the fly and and we went into
Havana I don't remember I think it was
83 some time George and I stayed in
contact and he would come by my house
and leave notes and stuff like that and
I would meet him and we'd go do things
together and he'd keep me up on what was
going on and he had had trouble after I
left because he had so much heat with
his indictments and things and I
couldn't stand out to your recollection
when was George indited well he was
indicted in 1980 with Richard Healey and
another fellow and Jairo Plata
the conspiracy on a dc-3 load into
Bimini and then he was indicted again
and 84 I think alright it may be an 82
and then one summer left passivity he
had several different indictments but
nothing ever became of them that I know
you said you went into Havana what do
you mean by that you just flew into
Havana right already no Vanna how'd you
manage to do that Jack my clearance well
I didn't know at the time Georgia just
playing a trick on me he said do it and
so we did it but I landed and went there
and I stayed by the aircraft and George
left and came back about an hour later
and we departed did you have a special
code or something that enabled you to
get in now that I know I did you at some
time get given a code to permit you to
overfly Cuba
yes George gave me a code a transponder
code what was the transponder code he
gave you one 301 when did he give you
that in 82 83 82 somewhere in that
period okay now did there come a time
when you stopped flying for George for
period hmm yes sir I started hormone a
little company there and 83 middle of 83
when you say your own company your own
drug smuggling company or some other
kind of come in sir yes sir I've bought
several aircraft him and one of the
business what kind of aircraft did you
buy come on up first my purchased was
they are twin Comanche and that had 320
320 340 gallons of fuel at a 3,000
nautical mile range and had an Omega
system which is a global navigation
system in it is this is this an airplane
you bought from a Pennsylvania company
yes it is this Pennsylvania company was
called air America that's correct
and what kind of planes did they have
where America was an aircraft
modification business long range fuel
engine modifications and that sort of
thing it was a place where people who
wanted to have the aircraft modified
went did you use this modified Comanche
for more drug flights yes sir I did
a for cocaine flights yes sir from where
to where from Colombia to the Middle
District of Florida where were you
operating out of late during this 1983
period Lakeland Florida right now
were you ever tracked by DEA or others
during this period of time no okay now
you talked about Richard Healey you knew
Richard Healey was involved with flying
narcotics correct correct
was Richard Healey also involved in
assisting the Contras in Central America
yes sir in what way was he assisting
them I don't know that it the extent in
which he was assistant existing the
Contras I he never really elaborated on
that he was very closed mouth about a
lot of things that he did or maybe I
just didn't ask any question Richard and
I had you know done a lot of things
together we've blown money from out to
Bahamas together and one time in 83 he
came to me and we flew a load of
grenades and some ship mines to Illya
pango let me let me sort of go through
that in greater detail had you ever
flown guns anywhere before
on occasion nowhere had you flown guns
to to Colombia and in whose airplane did
you fly guns to Colombia
George's Morales what did you do with
the guns you flew in Colombia well I
just got there and off loaded and
unloaded on the contraband the marijuana
or whatever and came back now the guns
that you flew came from where you flew
out of Florida yes sir all the guns came
out of Florida out of opa-locka right at
George's office what kind of guns do you
recall
well I'm not a gun expert senator or
ar-15s pistols ammunition that sort of
thing how would this be packaged for the
flight in their cases and boxes and
stuff like that yeah and you could fly
what about 2,000 pounds or oh I could in
those occasions going to Columbia I
never had quite that much I'm anywhere
from five hundred to a hundred maybe a
thousand pounds so you flew guns down
out of Florida did you have a permit no
you know where the guns came from no you
would load the guns on the plane fly
down to Colombia drop off guns pick up
drugs is that accurate well I didn't
load the aircraft Jairo Plata would load
it and I would come to the aircraft it
would be loaded there know what kind of
aircraft was this panther you flew the
panther down you landed in a strip in
Colombia mm-hmm and once the guns were
out was something else put in the plane
yes
marijuana are equated and you flew those
back yes to where the great great Harbor
key and while you were engaged these
flights were in what period of time but
those flights were during 1982 I would
say shortly thereafter Richard Healey
invited you to go on a flight to illah
pango Air Force Base in El Salvador yes
that's great
when was that and I think was May of 83
can you describe how that came about
well George had brought up the Georgian
company I don't know how it all went six
or eight Brazilian registered dc-3s OC
47 and he sold them and and used if you
have more heavy I wasn't involved and
all that but Richard and I flown to get
a considerable Mountain we're
those friends and he asked me if I want
to take a trip to Elia pango and I said
sure and so what does it pay I mean I
was into getting paid for my work and he
said on about 300,000 I said yeah you
give me two and you take one I'll go he
said it's a deal so I met him in
opa-locka that morning and went through
the aircraft with him aircraft was
already loaded with grenade launchers I
didn't look to see what it was I mean I
later found out that's what it was but
when I say you later found out when did
you find out well when I got down there
we all floated it so you actually saw a
grenade launchers being offload m79 I'm
about 40 of them and this was in what
kind of aircraft dc-3 how did you manage
to land flying from where you flew a
Telepan go well we left from opa-locka
and got into Boca Chica
I'd say around noon or the laughter noon
Boca chuckles Naval Air Station out in
the keys there were people there waiting
for us
no this is a Naval Air Station Naval Air
Station open/closed
well I think was kind of a reserve base
at the time but there were military
aircraft on the ground you landed there
yes and did you have a flight plan
clearance of any kind no and then
where'd you go we left Boca Chica and
went to Ilya pango what did you load at
the base at Boca Chica ship mines and I
was given name aluminum tube had some
maps in it and I manila envelope as I
recall I had the name Chris on it and I
was instructed
Richard was instructed and I was
standing there with him to deliver this
to Chris in a of mango and that when we
met there we'd be led to the place
called the Aero Club which was on I
could recall it's on the southwest side
of the field the Aero Club at the yellow
pango base right who met you at the
yellow pen go base well a truck Medus
there and when we got out and then there
was a guy the name of Chris they got the
envelope in the
Maps was Chris El Salvadoran no he was
an American it's America they D identify
himself to you no I didn't make other
than he was Chris did you have any
conversation with him he asked us if we
want to go to the hotel and I talked to
Richard about it and we've we said all
we want is gas hell did you know who
Chris worked for or who he represented
no I didn't know no I had some
assumptions but I didn't know did
Richard Healy tell you who he worked for
no your assumption was what that it was
a department defense or CI or something
like that
what made you assume that well after
having been on the ground for so many
years in working in the Bahamas and
Colombia and all out of different places
and hanging out with George Morales and
seeing all these things came down it was
just a normal thing to assume what kind
of truck was this that picked up these
weapons a large green military truck as
I recall you know and they had to the
ship mines were loaded forward between
grenade launchers they had a difficult
time stack him in there and getting the
netting around them and securing them
and and so they took him out you know by
hand
scoot him down the aircraft and and out
the door and loaded in the truck how
many people were offloading number five
or six guys there were they American or
else alone they were Spanish speaking el
Salvadorans I suppose in uniform yes and
was this at an isolated part of the base
it was down past the terminal it's
pretty isolated as a military looked
like it was all military there you say
your interest was in getting fuel and
leaving well that was my interest yes
did you in fact do that yes we got fuel
about 6:00 in the morning and where did
you go to straight to a little town in
northern Colombia called Rio hotcha is
just east of Santa Marta about 40 50
miles what did you do in Rio Hydra we
landed and feel the aircraft and
people are waiting for us what kind of
people Colombians
what was the purpose of that landing we
picked up a load of marijuana and
departed as soon as possible to great
harbor key that was all arranged I mean
I knew I wasn't ever ething he was going
to come down before I went how did you
know everything was going to come down
because Richard gave me the flight plan
so how much marijuana did you load
onboard this airplane understood later
was six thousand pound so you fly whose
airplane wasn't well it was the George's
airplane it was this airplane used
regularly in Rose King
what was this airplane used in drug
trafficking the aircraft had had a
sticker on Ella nope it was customs are
our DEA or even the FAA could have been
an FAA sticker but I do recall that they
had it had had a sticker on aircraft it
was grounded for some reason at one time
another you don't know so somebody had
to arrange to to release the aircraft to
go do what it did how did you happen to
notice that was that unusual to you or
well that particular aircraft had some
pretty good radios in it have all the
ones they had that was the only one that
had decent radios in it I do recall that
much about it you remember the kinds of
radios pardon do you remember the kinds
of radios mmm I think we had a KR 85
which is a king it's not the best king
but it is a good ADF and and I had a
couple of was narcotic with narcho
radios a small aircraft radios but they
work fine where did you notice the
sticker on the left side of the fuselage
on the rear past the door it was a cargo
type door I had that double hinge door
on it now
let's be precise about the period of
time again if we can do you recall when
this was 1983 1983 and remember what
month I am pretty sure it was May now
subsequent to that did you have occasion
to fly again for George Morales yes I
flew on different occasions for him
miscellaneous things made a few trips to
Colombia for him were those narcotics
trips again yes this is during 83 84 83
and I didn't I don't think I flew
pointman 84 I didn't run into him again
until July of 84 did you in fact earn
$200,000 for that flight you describe
Dilip Ango yes I did is that more than
you would earn for normal drug flights
usually a dc-3 load pays a hundred
thousand yeah considerably more now
after the flight with Richard Healey you
were also at the same time flying your
own cocaine flights is that accurate I
started right after that so you were
beginning to make even better money for
yourself correct that's correct I had
two partners my function was a Hennelly
aircraft and and and trying to pilots at
that time they didn't want me flying
anymore I mean so I had to power pilots
who didn't want you flying my partners
why because I was too valuable otherwise
now did there come a time when you lost
a flight I guess April 84 how did that
happen well the guy was caught on the
ground where the driver was caught in
Glades County in Florida yes and what
were the circumstances it was being
caught he was trying to get out or come
in well he had the load in the truck and
he was driving out I I didn't know the
guy and so I don't know all the
circumstances on that all I know is I
got home at one o'clock in the morning I
got a phone call and they say we lost
the load
and so I just packed my bags and locked
my doors and left you let me know what
the situation the circumstances why were
none of my people got busted I mean the
pilots got away and was security
aircraft and at this point you decided
that you were going to retire for the
second time yes sir because well because
I didn't want to work anymore it was too
risky okay now we're going to come back
we're going to take a brief recess and
come back and talk about the George
Morales and Costa Rica trips after the
recess will take 15-minute recess
stand in recess 15 minutes